[music]
yes, yes,
and there was another bag like this, you know, how they
used to show
such chemistry, how they hung it in people's
houses, it was so tight, like a beast, it covered the
head like that, that's why each one of us
went out at once, we took these bags for
that, because they were freer, and we put them on
Every year, there were such people in our house, they immediately took us
to the second floor and the red floor on the
stairs.
But we are not victorious, because we are Ukrainians.
We will always be Ukrainians and strong,
and they connected all their acquaintances to
find out and told him that they would not
let
her out if she was in  the prison will not be released, maybe on
Monday, maybe not released at all,
terrible, terrible, not understanding what is
happening, what will be next, the
unknown, sounds from outside, the grandchildren of the
questioning people, and everything is very bad, I really wanted to
get out there faster, it turns out,
we opened the lid of the
toilet, there was such a valve, it was
just necessary  to remove so that the water constantly
flowed on constantly flowed and
naturally there was a sound of a waterfall, the
sound distracted from the sound a little
We opened the
water tap, put a plate in it, and then the water
flowed, and it flowed all night long,
as long as there was water in the city.